So the way that you run a transaction
in Objectify, is equal ofy().transact, at the start of
the transaction and you specify new work and
if you don't want the transaction to return anything,
then you would use new void work instead
of work. And then you call the run method,
and then inside the run method you do the
stuff you want done inside the transaction, and if
your transaction expects a return result. Don't forget
to return it. There are some things that are
different in transactions in Objectify and in the raw
Java store API. For example, Objectify does not use
snapshot isolation. This can affect the outcome of
queries and gets inside a transactions. My advice is
to try to limit your use of transactions. So
that you only do updates inside a transaction because
it can be confusing to know exactly, what the
outcome of queries will be. Anyway, I encourage you
to read about transactions in the Objectify developer guide.
So go ahead and implement the to do's in register
for conference. And when you've implemented the function, run
the app on local host and try registering for
conference. You could use the API's explorer to test
out the new functionality to register for conference. I find
it's easiest to query conferences and then to copy
one of the website's key strings of the conference
that I'm going to want to attend. Now I
can go and register for the conference. You have to
have the web safe key string. So, I'm going to
enter it here and I'm going to execute function and
we'll see what got back. Result, true. So, hopefully
that means I am in fact registered for that conference.
Let's take a look in the datastore admin. I'm on
local hosts, I'm going to go to the admin console
on local hosts, and list the profiles and there I
am, and I'm registered for conference. You can see that
I can't tell from here what the name of the
conference is. But programmatically, you can take the conference key
and from that, you can define the conference name, if
you wanted to. You should also find that the UI
works, for registering for a conference. And you see that
it says that you can unregister from a conference. Well actually,
it won't work to unregister from a conference because you haven't
yet, implemented the functionality to do that. So now its your
turn to go ahead and write the code for implement
register for a conference. For the profile class need to have
the conference keys to attend property and your also going to
need to write the methods to get add and remove values.
Then you're going to need to copy the
skeleton code for register for conference into conference API.
And then fill in the ToDo's in registerForConference in
the Conference API class. Don't forget when you copy
over the registerForConference skeleton, you're going to need to
make sure you also copy over the wrapped boolean
class. When you implement registerForConference, you'll notice that the
method is defined to throw some exceptions, and you
need to honor that. If you change the way the method
behaves, for example, you change the exceptions that it throws, or
it throws different exceptions, or it doesn't throw them in the
right place, the UI for registering for conferences won't work properly.
And then to check what happens when you try to register
for a conference that has no seats available. Just create a
conference with zero seats left. The easiest way to create a
conference with zero seats left is that when you create the conference
just set max attendees to zero. If you want to see
what happens if you try to register for a conference that you've
already registered for you'll need to use the API's Explorer. Because
the conference page in the UI will know if you've already registered
and won't offer you the option to register again. So how
did you check that your code worked? Did you check that the
conference keys to attend property of the profile entity, contains a string
of the conference key? Or did you look to see if the
conference keys to attend property of the profile, contains the conference
name? Did you check, if the seats available of the conference? Is
one less than the max of the attendees of the conference.
And did you try registering for a conference that you had created?